D
REPUBLICANS ARE SKEPTICAL OF
THAT.
SOCIAL MEDIA CONSUMED BY
YOUNGEST PEOPLE, VOTERS 18-29.
THERE WAS ONE SELL TO THEM IN
THIS MIDTERM, WHICH WAS USED TO
MOTIVATE THEM, WHICH WE ALWAYS
KNEW WAS A SHAM AND IT REALLY,
REALLY WAS.
JOE BIDEN DECIDED HE WAS GOING
TO FORGIVE STUDENT LOAN, UP TO
$5,000 IN STUDENT LOANS AND
TURNS OUT THE WHOLE PLAN WAS
FALLING APART AND HERE'S A TWEET
FROM NED RYAN SAYING
FASCINATING.
MOTIVATED UNDER 30S TO OUT AND
VOTE -- COME OUT AND VOTE
MEANING STUDENT LOAN FORGIVENESS
AND IN THE END BIDEN GOT WHAT HE
WANTED AND THEY GOT PLAYED FOR
FOOLS.
GIVE MORE CONTEXT, WILL.
WILL: YEAH, PEOPLE ARE SAYING
FAIRLY AND INACCURATELY THIS WAS
A CON JOB BECAUSE THE BIDEN
STUDENT LOAN HANDOUT PROGRAM HAS
BEEN THROWN OUT BY A FEDERAL
DISTRICT COURT IN TEXAS SAYING
HE DIDN'T HAVE THE POWER,
CONSTITUTIONALLY, TO DO THIS.
THE JUDGE SAYS I'M NOT SAYING
WHETHER OR NOT THIS IS GOOD
POLICY, THAT'S UP TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
HE DOESN'T HAVE THE EXECUTIVE
POWER TO GO IN AND FORGIVE
STUDENT LOANS.
THAT'LL BE APPEALED AND IF IT'S
IN TEXAS, IT'LL GO TO THE FIFTH
CIRCUIT AND THAT'S AN INSANE
APPELLANT DISTRICT AND DOESN'T
LOOK LIKE IT WOULD SURVIVE AND
BIDEN'S FEDERAL LOAN SYSTEM
WOULDN'T SURVIVE AND MANY SAY
THEY NEVER THOUGHT IT WOULD.
IT WAS A PLOY TO GET YOUNG
PEOPLE MOTIVATED TO VOTE IN THE
MIDTERMS.
HE SAYS GIVE BIDEN CREDIT,
STUDENT LOAN FORGIVENESS WAS
CYNICAL AND DISHONEST AND THE
BEST BAIT AND SWITCH SCHEME IN
MODERN POLITICAL HISTORY.
RACHEL: THE NEW YORK POST ALSO
WEIGHING IN THROUGH EDITORIAL
BOARD SAYING BIDEN STUDENT DEBT
CON JOB FUELED GENERATION Z FOR
THE MIDTERMS.
WILL THE KIDS WAKE UP?
NO.
PETE: THEY WENT ONTO WRITE, THE
NEW YORK POST WRITES, "THE PLOY
HAS TO COUNT AS A BRILLIANT
PIECE OF LOW DOWN SNEAKIEST AND
GAINED THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
PARTY THE ELECTORAL WORLD.
FRANKLY WE THOUGHT THE BIG GUY
WAS PAST SHARP CREDIT LIKE THAT
AND BIDEN DRIVING THE KIDS DEEP
ERIC INTO HIS HANDS AND WILL THE
UNDER 30S WAKE UP AND REALIZE
THAT HAD GUY HORN SWAG -LED OR
FALL HARDER FOR THE LONG CON""?
WILL: THEY'RE NOT GETTING THEIR
MONEY BECAUSE IT'S
UNCONSTITUTIONAL FOR BIDE TON
PROMISE THAT.
RACHEL: THIS IS ASSUMING THE
NUMBERS FOR YOUNG PEOPLE THEY
SWUNG THIS ELECTION FOR BIDE AND
THIS IS ASSUMING THAT THE
STUDENT LOAN PROGRAM IS WHAT DID
IT.
I DON'T BUY IT.
MY TAKE AWAY FROM THE ELECTION.
INDOCTRINATION WORKS.
YOU HAD CORY DEANGELES ON.
INDOCTRINATION WORKS AND NOT
JUST IN THE SCHOOLS BUT HAPPYING
THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA AND I DON'T
WANT TO BELABOR WHAT I BROUGHT
UP BEFORE BUT ESSENTIALLY BIG
TECH IS WORKING IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE DEMOCRATIC
ADMINISTRATION AND CANDIDATES TO
TURN UP THEIR VOICES ON SOCIAL
MEDIA AND TURN DOWN OTHER
VOICES.
IF THIS IS TRUE, WE NEED TO GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF IT AND LOOKS
LIKE IT IS BASED ON STUDIES DONE
BY DR. EPSTEIN, THIS IS AN
IN-KIND DONATION TO THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY.
IF IT'S TRUE, ALL OF OUR
ELECTIONS ARE A MIRAGE BECAUSE
WE CAN'T HAVE THEM WEIGHING IN
LIKE THAT.
WHAT I'M SAYING IS KIDS HAVE
BEEN INDOCTRINATED ON CLIMATE
CHANGE AND YOU NAME THE ISSUE
AND THEY'RE ALL IN ON THE WOKE
POLICIES.
PETE: K-12 SCHOOLS THEN THE
REINFORCEMENT MECHANISM OF
SOCIAL MEDIA OF WHAT YOU WANT TO
THINK AND THEN GO VOTE FOR SIX
WEEKS WITHOUT AN ID AND NOW KNOW
WHO YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO VOTE FOR,
VOTE FOR JOHN FETTERMAN IN
PENNSYLVANIA BEFORE THE DEBATE.
THAT'S WHAT A LOT OF PEOPLE DID
AND THEY'RE WINNING OVER BIGGER
NUMBERS THAN EVER OF YOUNG
PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN TOLD
AMERICA IS A BAD PLACE, YOU CAN
CHANGE YOUR GENDER AND MORE.
RACHEL: THE INDOCTRINATION THAT
GOES TO YOUR CHILD'S PHONE IS
CURATED TO THEM.
MY YOUNG GIRLS WERE GETTING
INUNDATED WITH PRO CHOICE,
YOU'RE GOING TO DIE IF YOU DON'T
HAVE THE RIGHT TO KILL SOMEONE
ELSE.
IT WAS ALL PRO CHOICE, PRO
CHOICE ON YOUNG WOMEN.
MAYBE USING OTHER MESSAGES ON
OTHER PEOPLE BUT WE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND OUR KIDS ARE OWNED BY
THE MESSAGES COMING THROUGH
SOCIAL MEDIA, AND THAT IS
INDOCTRINATION WORKS.
IT WORKED IN ALL KINDS OF
TOTALITARIAN SYSTEMS BEFORE.
>> I'LL WRAP IT UP HERE.
WE'LL IS THE SAME QUESTION.
WILL: WHEN DO YOU REALIZE THE
POLICIES BEING PROMISED TO YOU
ARE THE LONG CON AND DON'T MAKE
YOU BETTER.
IT WAS ONE PASSED ON THE YOUNG
GENERATION AND IT WAS WEARINESS
GOING TO G